food that was made for the mistress must have been poisoned by
several hands before it was brought into this room.
One day, around the time it was discovered that Tamayosu was pregnant, her second
daughter, who was the poisoner at the time, was poisoned twice, and her nerves were
so affected that she still can't move her arms and legs.
There is no abnormal taste or odor.There is no such poison.When I
was at Hanamachi's house, I tried various things with my arms as experiments, and I was also a
scientist.My
body gradually became infected with poison, so many
poisons no longer worked.  To be honest, I'm
not cut out for poison, but in a sense I'm lucky to have this position.I
think it would be better to change the plate you're wearing to a silver star one that reacts more easily to poison.Just as Hitoshi-sama
said.  I purposely used pottery
to test you.